[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained as always my name is
caleb denby
and today i'm going to be walking you
through some opening lessons to be
learned
from the chess 9lx event that actually
just wrapped up
so we're going to take a look at some of
the biggest opening sort of disasters
and successes
throughout the event and see if we can
apply anything learned
to some real chess examples that i'm
going to get to sort of near the end
so there are two main opening topics
that i want to focus on for tonight
that are sort of accentuated in chess
960.
so in these chest 960 games you'll
oftentimes find a lot of very early
pressure or attacks
on a specific weak point in the position
players will identify sort of a starting
weakness in
the initial position that they're given
and
base their opening play around it so
that's topic number one
and topic number two that i want to
focus on is the idea of being left with
one bad
piece this is something that often
happens in 960
players are able to develop almost all
of their pieces but then there seems to
be one
piece that sort of gets left behind and
that can be
detrimental to the entire chess position
so let's jump into it here
the first game i wanted to show you guys
is one between hikaru nakamura
and peter svidler from the event and
this is actually one
that nakamura perhaps did not capitalize
on
to the fullest extent had naka won this
game he would have walked away with
clear first in the events
instead of course he shares that first
place prize with magnus carlson but
let's see what happened here
so this is the initial position we were
given
rather they were given and it's a rather
interesting one right we have the
bishops on their initial starting
squares so probably not going to be
too many difficulties getting these guys
developed any
you know normal centralized pawn move
will help to develop these guys
the king is starting in a fairly safe
position on the queen side
next to this rook the queen also in its
initial position
is likely going to be able to develop
without too many problems
but then we get to these nights over
here in the corners
and we'll see that these nights
sort of become the story of the opening
play in this game
uh so let's see how both players treated
the developing of the knights in this
game and who
it worked out better for so nakamura
starts out with the move one to e4
and this is a very sensible move it
helps develop the bishop helps develop
in fact this rook
and the queen right in all aspects
probably the best opening move here for
white black
responded peter did with the move d5
which is a perfectly sensible move
so in regular chess of course this is
looking
similar to the scandinavian and the
scandinavian is sort of sometimes seen
as slightly dubious because after
captures captures
the queen can immediately be attacked
with a move like knight c3
of course that's not actually going to
be an option here for white
as the knights are located all the way
over on the king's side so this was
peter's opening idea
we also see in real chess that the queen
does sometimes develop
out to the center early on uh if this
idea of knight c3 is for some reason not
really available
to white or of course
the same applies in reverse with black
not being able to kick away a queen on
d4 with knight c6 and many sicilians
that we'll see
in the game though hikaru was well aware
of this so he pushed the pawn
up to e5 instead and now
peter spidler plays a really interesting
move of bishop f5
so fans of the kero khan i'm sure well
aware of this idea you push
c6 d5 if white plays the advance you can
develop this bishop out to f5 but i
wanted to ask the chat room
what your initial impression of this
move bishop f5 is
what do you feel in your heart about the
move bishop f5
is it a good move or a bad move
let's talk about it
same impression as hikaru so of course
the chat is
referencing hikaru nakamura a very
expressive player
did make quite a number of faces when
peter first
played this move bishop f5
so on the stream the commentators were
also very critical of this move bishop
f5
because it does allow white to develop
with tempo with the move knight g3
of course white now solving this problem
of where to put these two knights
uh quite early on by bringing this
knight out to g3 with tempo
however i think the problem actually
goes a lot deeper
than simply losing a tempo in the
opening while obviously losing a tempo
isn't good
black's problems are much much more
severe than the
simple loss of a tempo here and that
problem is
this knight on h8 with this bishop now
sitting on g6 we'll see it later gets
harassed back to the h7 square
the big problem for black in this
position
is that this knight is simply going to
be unable to develop itself
and we'll see that black makes some very
very serious concessions
quite early on in an attempt to get this
night out to a reasonable square
but with good play peter never should
have gotten this knight into the game
and would have been facing a very very
difficult game
hicaro continued reasonably accurately
with h4
we see h6 by black to give this bishop a
flight square of course h5 was
threatening to trap it
caro now advances with h5 and we see now
bishop h7
of course though this knight still
unable to develop out to g6
is going to be facing some very very
serious issues
white now continues with d4 black plays
the move e6
and white develops with bishop d3 and
these are all very natural moves that
you would expect
in a kero khan except of course this
knight
is on h8 rather than c8
right black would much prefer to have
this knight
here and this rook here and then he
would have a very natural
uh cairo con position and everything
would be fine because
all of black's pieces could develop out
sorry not on c8 on b8 rather
all of black's pieces could develop out
naturally
however here we'll see after bishop
takes d3 and queen takes d3 black's
position
is is quite simply awful not only can
this knight not develop
it's now in direct danger of being lost
tactically
after the move queen h7 and because of
this
peter already has to play this awkward
looking move f5
and after f5 white now has permanent
advantage
advantages in this position f5 is not a
move
that black was interested in playing it
weakens the e6 square
the g6 square it sort of leaves this g
pawn in the dust being hampered now by
white's h-pawn and it doesn't even solve
all of the problems that this knight
actually has
so in the game hicaro played a very very
bad move which is
e takes f6 this move is just simply
wrong and
it allows black now to find some freedom
with his pieces this bishop can get to
an open diagonal
this knight has natural development and
this knight as well
is going to be able to come to some
pretty natural squares
after the move knight f7 if instead
hicario had chosen a more accurate move
like knight 1 to e2 or knight h3 heading
for this f4 square
we would have seen a situation where
hikaru is utilizing
all of his pieces while peter is going
to be unable to find an effective use
for this night and already peter of
course has made
some very distinct weaknesses in his
positions
in his position just to save this knight
so
if the game had continued with knight 1
to e2
we might have seen some moves such as
knight to e7
knight f4 now due to the weakness on e6
this knight would have to move again
something like knight to c6
this bishop would come out to e3 knight
f7 for example
is an attempt to develop we could even
see white castle
king side and now after knight g5 you
might think that this
knight is serving a useful purpose but
the simple move f3
and now it's very very clear that this
knight is doing absolutely nothing on
the g5 square
it has no forward prospects
it is for the moment defending this pawn
on e6 but sort of in a very awkward
manner
and of course coming back to f7 or h7 is
not going to improve
black's position and quite honestly i
would
be very willing to call this position
just strictly winning
for white out of the opening white can
in the future look to expand on the
queen side with something like c4
the black king is going to be rather
stuck over here and
uh you know sort of a ready-made attack
for white
this knight has prospects of coming back
to e2 the car could also potentially
invade on the king side with knight g6
and knight f4
and the game i think would be very very
easy to play
to say the least for karu and very
difficult now for peter svidler
instead of course we did see this move e
takes f6
plate instead and i think this is just a
pretty terrible mistake
by uh hikaru nakamura it allows peter
svidler to actually capture with the
queen as well
aiming for this f2 pawn and then we'll
see in a few short moves
uh it's actually cars pieces that end up
being
slightly awkwardly placed black queen
side castles
we see knight g4 queen h4
knight e5 and this horrible knight on h8
now trades itself off for this knight on
e5
and all of black's pieces find
reasonably harmonious squares
without too much difficulty bishop d2 is
played knight c6
f4 bishop c5 and black's pieces are
controlling the center
this knight is looking a little bit out
of place for whites
with a lot of pressure on all of white's
weaknesses that have been created
and even the rooks for black are going
to have useful
squares on the back rank to either
support the center
or challenge white on the half open file
so all in all what should have been an
opening disaster for
peter ended up being a reasonable
position for him in fact
one that he could have gone on to win
had he played a bit better in the middle
game
uh but at the end of the day uh the
players
did end up drawing this position after
of course a very complex game as
they are known to have but the the
points i wanted to highlight in the game
are these opening decisions that were
made by either player and how they very
directly led
to a worse position for peter and then a
perfectly fine position for peter this
move bishop f5 is where the problems all
started
not necessarily because it gives up a
tempo yes that is
sort of a bad aspect of this move but
definitely because it's taking away
any future development that this knight
could have had
all right with that in mind let's take a
look at another example from
this event where the opening didn't
quite go
according to plan and this time we're
actually going to see hikaru nakamura
on the other side of things of course
this is another case where the good
opening position
didn't result in the result
that the player was going to hope for
but we'll see
that alireza actually managed to apply
quite a bit of pressure to hikaru
from the opening in this position and
once again
these ideas are going to start as early
as move two move
three so in this initial position
we have ali reza well actually both
players
with a bishop starting opposite a queen
and this is a very interesting dynamic
that of course you don't see too often
in normal chess openings but does appear
sometimes
in chess 960. and in addition to that
there are also some weaknesses in the
initial starting position and we're
going to see that that
is going to be very very relevant in
this case so of course last game we had
the idea
of one piece sort of being uh sort of
trapped due to an
early mistake by black in this case
we're going to see how
alireza managed to force that kind of
favorable situation
by attacking some of the weak points in
the black camp
so right off the bat who in the chat can
tell me what points are a little bit
susceptible
to an early attack in this chess 960
position
who knows who can tell me
so professor l axis has the right idea
here
both f7 and f2 are looking quite
vulnerable in the
initial position uh you can also notice
that
a7 and a2 are undefended as well
no pieces on the back ring defend them
but we'll see in the game
that that was the less relevant weakness
because
the move b3 is very natural and was
played first and foremost
so with this diagonal closed it's not as
easy to get to a2
and then b6 was played for black as well
and so already i would like to
turn the question to the chat room again
white to move
and pose black some very very serious
problems
all right white to move and pose black
we'll pose some some questions to to
black
there are already significant issues
in the black position that require very
accurate play to avoid getting
a worse position right out of the
opening
right out of the gate
what can we do here
so yeah of course the the first thing to
notice is that these bishops
are for the moment hindering some
natural development for both sides so
that's definitely going to come into
play here
is how can we continue to hamper our
opponent's development
so okay as i said the other idea
is we want to take advantage of these
weak points in the position using these
weak points alireza managed to
force some very serious concessions from
hikaru
already from move two
so the move i'm thinking of the chat
room has not gotten it so if you still
want to think about it
go ahead and pause the video here the
move is actually to play this simple
move
knight f3 you might be thinking what is
what is knight f3 right this isn't
this is nothing right why is knight f3
such a big deal well first and foremost
this isn't going to be the type of
position where black is happy about
giving up the bishop pair
of course that is a huge concession that
uh high-level grandmasters are never
going to want to do
this early on and so with that move
out of the way white is quite simply
preparing his natural development of g3
and bishop g2 and after this comes into
play
all of white's pieces are going to be in
the game of course aside from the rooks
which
can be figured out sort of a little bit
later on his works will be free to move
on the back rank
support the center or had any half open
files
so not only is white preparing the
natural development of the rest of his
pieces
notably also the white queen would be in
effect on
a long diagonal battery so the white
queen would even have a use
but he's actually threatening to play
the move knight g5 now is he going to
play knight g5 against any old
move of course not but if black tries to
respond in suit
with the moved knight f6 now all of a
sudden either knight e5
or knight g5 is a very very serious
problem
this weak point on f7 is suddenly almost
indefensible
uh black can play the move king e8s but
of course this is really not what black
is interested
in doing giving up castling rights so
early on would of course
again be a huge concession and black of
course could also consider the move
bishop d5
but after this the move c4 bishop e6
of course this bishop is not in its
ideal placement
staring at this pawn on c4 and some very
strange squares
on the queen side as well and from here
white could do
a number of things to increase the
pressure simple development would be
fine
d4d5 would already be very very
threatening
and even moves like f4 and f5 still
trying to get at this f7 weakness
very much could be considered here for
ali reza
so with all of that in mind black is
sort of unable to play the move knight
f6
without getting a worse position after
the move knight f3
and we see that the symmetry is already
being broken
quite early on in the game hikaru chose
the move
f6 but this is quite simply in a move
admitting that black is going to be
worse out of the opening
uh perhaps a little bit better for
hikaru would have been to try the
interesting move
e6 now of course if something like
knight g5 or knight e5 were to be played
the move knight d6 is available to black
so it keeps this option open
and now it's probably not actually in
white's best interest to go for this
so what if white just continues develop
naturally continues to develop naturally
with
g3 well now after e6 knight f6
is actually going to be playable of
course now
with g3 we have introduced a pin to the
queen so these moves are less good
in fact this would be losing a piece for
white so those tactics not going to work
out and so after knight f6
bishop g2 it's true that black cannot
keep total symmetry with g6
after playing e6 you wouldn't want to
weaken that many dark squares
but bishop e7 would be playable and from
here natural development could ensue
something like d4 takes takes knight c6
and we'll see here that all of the black
pieces are going to be
in the game and even the queen
can get into the action for black for
example after knight c3
uh sorry for bishop b2 for example
wouldn't want to give up the bishop
uh castles knight c3 h6
castles and queen h7 and we see that
black is able to complete development
even the queen
eyeing some nice squares on this open
diagonal and all of the black pieces
participating in the game
now let's compare this with what happens
to hikaru
after the move f6 of course f6
isn't a developing move in fact it's
taking squares away
from the black pieces and so with this
early attack
not even a direct attack but the threat
of an attack to a weak point
in hikaru's camp early on ali reza has
gained significant opening advantages
let's see how he continued to press
those
he started with simple development of g3
c5 bishop g2
hikaru now unable to develop the knight
to f6 had to settle for knight c7
instead which is i think just a worse
square
c4 is the continuation and now
and perhaps black could consider trying
to play something like g6 but again
knight g5 threats are in the air and
white can start breaking in the center
already
instead hikaru chose e6 we see white
castle
bishop e7 and now with a developmental
advantage
thanks to some time wasted by black
alireza
breaks in the center with the move d4
hikaru chose to simply castle
and now i would like to turn it over to
the chatroom again
white to move and cause black some some
very serious difficulties
once again
white to move and give black some very
serious difficulties
so there are some good ideas in the chat
and i won't lie to you normal moves like
rick fd1 like rook cd1
even a simple move like bishop b2 these
all maintain the advantage
but alireza found the very interesting
move d5
and the point of this move is to
start an attack on these light squares
in black's center
if you ignore this move for example
white is just going to have a very nice
open bishop along this long diagonal
and if you capture on d5 as hikaru did
then you're going to be met with a move
like knight h4 this pawn on e6
has given up control over this f5 square
white threatens to come to it and of
course this pawn is now pinned
along this long open diagonal and this
might be an idea you're familiar with
from normal chess that does sometimes
occur in the queen's
indian defense but let's continue
hakara found the best move which is to
play the move f5
defending the square with the rook now
and interesting introducing the idea of
bishop takes h4
we see knight c3 by alireza attempting
to regain the pawn
bishop takes g takes h5 but now already
knight d5 takes takes takes
takes and white more or less
has a winning advantage straight out of
the opening
the reason for that being he was unable
to get this queen into the game
and decaro had to waste a lot of time
and go for inferior development thanks
to this opening pressure
that ali reza managed to apply in the
game hikaru played the move king h7
and now after queen back to f3 this pawn
is very very difficult
to defend in the game mccarthy played
the move rook c6
we see the move king h1 queen g8
and then if alareza had captured a free
pawn he would have enjoyed
a very substantial advantage i think
about plus two according to the computer
but in the game unfortunately he chose
rook g1 and this
started to give away a lot of the
advantage back to hikaru
when after g6 hikaru has preserved
his king side pawns white should still
be a bit better because this knight on
b8 hasn't gotten into the game yet
but in the game unfortunately faruja was
just a bit outplayed by hikaru
and karo did manage to walk away with
the full point
but that's not the point of this lecture
the point of this lecture was this
outstanding opening play
we see the subtle move knight f3
allowing white to develop all of his
pieces
naturally and forcing black into a very
awkward situation where he was forced to
play this
slightly unhappy move of f6 which
interferes with the rest of his
[Music]
development
why doesn't white mind getting those
double isolated rook pawns well let's
take a look
right and in this case white doesn't
mind because
of these very forcing variations the
open g file actually helps him
and he's just so ahead in development
that
these weaknesses created by black are
more than uh are going to more than
compensate
for any weaknesses of the double
isolated pawns
also uh this idea of bishop takes knight
is very much a double-edged one
many of you might be familiar with a
famous bobby fischer game against boris
baskey where something similar happened
giving up this dark squared bishop for
this night can be a very risky maneuver
right and we see in the game
that ali reza gets good dominance over
this long diagonal
thanks to this bishop sacrificing itself
for the knight on h4
all right i want to keep moving things
along here we have a lot to go over
tonight
so let's take a look at another game
between
wesley so and alireza for ruja
and finally we get to see the youngster
not only playing well in the opening but
actually converting on his
advantage alireza did have a couple very
impressive games despite not having the
greatest score overall in the tournament
uh but i was most impressed really with
the positions he was getting out of the
opening in many of these games against
the world's best players
after queen f3 would king jake get a
repetition or white has more there yeah
white is definitely not obliged to
repeat moves in that position
and i think a move like king h1 and rook
g1 to follow would be very very good
for for white there manny white's not
interested in repeating
uh let's continue though in this game we
have i believe
a very very similar position uh as to
what we looked
looked at in game one in fact i think
it's the same position from the same
round with the knights
stuck in the corners and here
once again we're going to see uh black
making use of a weak point in the white
camp
so let's take a look e4 e5 was played in
the game
like i said very natural of course in
peter's game we saw the move d5 which
led to a bad position for black
but e5 is very natural and
in the game wesley so actually starts
with the move knight g3
solving the problem of the knight in the
corner immediately
and now who here can tell me why knight
g3
might be a bad move for white
in this position already we see on move
two
mistakes are being made by the players
so black to move and take advantage of
knight to g3
so some people in the chat are
suggesting the move g6 which is pretty
natural
you just want to hamper this knight's
development but
that sort of falls under the trap of
taking away your own developmental
squares
of course the problem with knight g3 is
that it leaves behind
this f2 pawn and this is going to be a
very critical weak point
and after alareza's second move bishop
c5 developing with tempo
attacking this weak square black is
already pretty significantly better
from move two not something you would
see every day
the reason for that is because it is
actually incredibly awkward for white to
defend this pawn
uh in the game we saw wesley so actually
choose this move
queen to e2 to defend it which of course
is not ideal
interfering with the development of
white's bishop
had he chosen something like queen f3
well he's sort of running into the same
issues where now this knight is not
going to have any
any square to develop out to also of
course you're asking for some danger
here
of getting this queen trapped with some
bishop g4 tactics that again
do occasionally show up in real chess if
you're familiar
also black can very much consider
breaking in the center immediately
with the move d5 so after ed5 for
example
knight f6 like i said these threats are
already looming
in the position and black is
significantly better so perhaps
fearing some of those threats wesley
chose the move queen e2
but now after knight g6 of course white
cannot respond in kind with bishop c4
and knight f4 is already keeping up the
pressure keeping up these threats
d3 was wesley so's choice but now after
knight f4
queen f3 we go ahead and see
ally reza play the interesting move pawn
to g5
uh in this move just cements this knight
on a great square
on f4 again white is not going to be
super happy about capturing
this guy giving black uncontested
control over this
critical dark square diagonal and this
queen on f3
once again not going to be a happy piece
with issues of bishop g4 to follow later
in the game
and so already like i said i love ali
reza's position
thanks to his early attack on a weak
point on f2 let's see how the game
continued we see bishop e3 by wesley
fighting back a little bit
d6 by alireza wasting no time in getting
developed
knight f5 by wesley so taking advantage
of this little hole
that uh frieza left behind knight f6 now
g3 is wesley's attempt to kick this
knight out but now we see
that because wesley has forced
has been forced into making some opening
concessions black no longer has to worry
as much about this light square diagonal
so while white couldn't really consider
taking an f4 thanks to this dark squared
bishop
white black very much can consider
taking this knight on f5
and did so in the game we see e takes f5
g4 queen d1 and now knight d5
and we see this knight unable to develop
itself
to its normal squares this bishop also
remaining undeveloped
and black controlling the center very
thoroughly with all of his pieces
in the game and a weakness on f5 to
very freely attack and this is just a
fantastic position
out of the opening for alireza that he
managed to convert into a full point
let's see how we continued we saw bishop
c5 dc5
h3 h5 takes takes and wesley finally
gets developed but now we see queen to
d7
f3 and alareza just picks up this pawn
on
f5 uh interestingly enough here uh the
move queen side castles is actually
significantly better
for ali reza thanks to some threats of
playing this move c4 and breaking open
in the center
but in the game farusha just captured
this free pawn and it was enough for him
to convert his advantage
into a full point again highlighting the
fact that wesley still
has not completed development and
farouja is already
up a full pawn in the game of course
he didn't get to keep the pawn forever f
takes g4 queen f2 was played
takes takes but of course these pawns on
the g file are going to be rather weak
and it's clear that ferruja has a
distinct advantage in development
central control and peace activity
uh okay so with all that in mind i want
to
switch gears a little bit now so we saw
what all of this looks like in chess 960
right we saw all of these opening
ideas uh mistakes starting from the
second move with the world's best
players
and these two big ideas of attacking a
weak point in the position
and hampering the development of one of
the opponent's pieces if you can keep
just one of the opponent's pieces
from getting into the game then it's
very likely that you
end up with an opening advantage and a
lot of you might be thinking
well that's great and all for chess 960
i'm glad i know this now about this one
chess variant
but these two ideas appear very very
often in
normal chess and that's the big secret
that no one is telling you
so uh well of course everyone is i'm
sure familiar with
the normal opening chess principles
things like develop your pieces control
the center
castle the king you might not be as
consciously aware of these ideas of
these early weak point attacks
and these early ideas of keeping
one piece in particular out of the game
so i want to switch gears now go from
these wonderful chess 960 games
to looking at some regular chess
openings
and how these ideas sort of manifest
from
the real initial position in chess
so let's click on over here and take a
look
at some weak points in chess so the
first
thing i want to start with is the move
e4 right
and black can respond in many ways of
course we have the french defense
after e6 and coming through we have d4
d5 knight c3 bishop b4
e5 c5 a3
bishop takes c3 b takes c3 and knight e7
so this of course
is just a theoretical position in the
french that many of you are probably
aware of
many of you might also be aware of the
main move to play for an advantage
for white in this position so
who can use one of these chess 960
principles
to tell me the main move for white in
this position how can white
play for an advantage out of the french
and well of course this is a theoretical
position and many of you just might
already know the move
that can definitely be
defined using this principle that we can
take from the game of chess 960.
so what should white play here so yeah
of course this is the start of the
poison pawn variation in the winowar
and the move queen g4 is the main move
and what is this idea
well we're simply attacking a weak point
very very early on
and it does force a concession from
black
either black allows us to take this pawn
on g7
going for the poison pawn accepted or
he can defend this pawn with an awkward
move like
king to f8 where black now gives up
castling rights
commits his king to the king's side and
is making a very serious concession
of course moves like rick g8 would sort
of be ridiculous
and queen g4 forces black into a little
bit of an
awkward position of course nowadays the
theory goes very very deep in the poison
pawn
but this is the same exact idea that we
see in chess 960
cropping up in regular chess white
attacks a weak point in the position and
black must
uh either concede that the g7 pawn is
lost
or make some other type of concession
like the move king to f8
so that was our first one let's take a
look at some other weak points in the
game
i want to go now to d4
we have d5 let's take a look at c4 to
begin with
c6 of course would be the slav and just
playing some natural opening moves
knight c3
knight f6 c takes d5 c takes d5
bishop f4 i would like you guys to tell
me
if the move bishop f5 is a good move for
black
and why is bishop f5 a good move for
black here
so once again we are very early on
in a normal chess game from the initial
position so many of you are probably
just aware
of the ideas here but if you find
yourself
in a position where you're not aware of
the ideas once again
this fallback of this weak point
principle
is quite useful in the opening stage of
chess
so bishop f5 of course as the chat room
is saying is
not the greatest move for black in these
positions because queen b3
applies some very awkward pressure to
this weak point here
on b7 of course there are also
some tactical implications involving
knight takes d5 as well
if queen b6 were to appear on the board
although i i don't think knight takes d5
actually works here because the d4 pawn
is hanging
but it does allow white at least to get
this pawn structure
which can be slightly awkward for black
here and i think this position is in
fact
a pretty uh pretty distinct advantage
for
white so once again you might consider
the move bishop f5 in some cases if
you're unaware
of the opening theory here necessarily
but
as we can see bishop f5 not going to be
a good move
thanks to this idea of queen b3 much
more common by the way for black is to
play knight c6
e3 and now you can follow it up with
bishop f5
as queen b3 it's a little bit less hard
as knight a5
is a good response to defend all of the
weaknesses in the black camp
black can also be a bit more cautious
with a move like a6
and now something like c1 for example
bishop f5
queen b3 is really not getting the job
done here
as now after knight a5 queen a4 check
there's even this move of b5 but
important point here developing the
knight out to c6 before bishop f5 and we
can start to understand
why when we look at this idea of weak
squares
in the opening
okay what about knight a5 and queen a4
yeah and that's just a theoretical line
the bishop would actually retreat back
to d7 there
and it's fine for black now
i want to take a look at a very very
similar idea again attacking a weak
point
in chess but i want to introduce the
idea
of white very very purposefully in this
case
attacking a weak point and the idea here
isn't so much that it sort of uh you
know just happens to be
if the opponent is developing
nonchalantly but white very actively
tries to attack a weak point in the
opening
so for example bishop f4 from white
would start the london variation we have
knight f6
e3 e6 and then there's a very
interesting line in the london that sort
of comes about
after this move knight to c3 this is
an idea sort of championed by yobaba and
richard rapport
and the idea is sort of multi-fold uh
number one
white often just sort of goes a little
bit crazy and launches some kind of
king-side attack
not moving this pawn allowing some queen
side castling potential
and developing this knight early but
number two this very directly
aims for a weak point who can tell me
what the weak point
is what is the weak point
in the position
and yeah of course professor axis has
the idea again
in this case it's going to be this pawn
on c7
and so if you're facing this with black
you might not
be totally aware of all of the
theoretical
ideas but you probably are aware of this
weak point on c7
thanks to these lessons we can take from
chess 960.
so as such black should be in my opinion
a little bit cautious about this
pawn on c7 for that reason the main
the main moves here are actually bishop
d6 is most common
immediately relieving some of this
pressure and the move bishop e4
is common as well in order to prevent
this knight from stepping to b5
attacking c7 once again these are the
main moves and believe it or not
the third most common move is the move
a6
and this very directly says i see what
you're up to
i'm not allowing you to play knight b5
but let's for the moment
say black continues a little bit naively
with bishop e7
still a perfectly fine move let's say
bishop d3
still continuing development and
something like knight b
to d7 now already as we see
in chess 960 games black is going to be
worse here
thanks to this idea of a weak point
being targeted
early on so
if knight b5 is played here black
already
is in a pretty terrible spot the only
way for him to defend this pawn
is to go bishop b4 check bishop a5 and
now after b4
bishop b6 we have the classic chess 960
case
of black making an early concession
because he
wasn't aware of a weak point in his
position
and as i said before this can occur in
real chess
as we are now seeing and so white of
course would be better here because this
bishop is way
way way out of play on the b6 uh square
staring at a very strong central pawn on
d4
so i want to open it up to questions a
little bit
any questions on this idea of targeting
weak points in regular chess openings
does anybody
have any questions about this one in
particular
any questions at all
all right if not i want to move on
to the second idea so this idea of
targeting a weak point in chess
does occur occur quite often as we are
seeing
and one last fun one i'm sure you all
are aware
of the weakest square in the starting
position in chess f7
being a common target especially for
beginners and of course there are ideas
of attacking this guy early on stuff
like the fred liver
going for scholars mate and these ideas
are very very well known
but they all sort of spring from the
same idea of attacking
a weak point with that in mind though
let's move on
to the second idea discussed in this
lecture
and this idea actually occurs even more
often
in real chess than the first so much so
that i think it should
sort of be taught along with the idea of
opening print
of the regular opening principles in
chess it sort of gets a mention
with the idea of developing your pieces
but what i'm specifically talking about
is when one player picks out a piece in
the enemy camp to sort of target
and what do i mean by that i don't mean
target as in trying to win that piece
they target a piece in order to make
sure
it can't develop comfortably and if they
succeed in this
if the bishop or knight cannot develop
comfortably
then the player can expect to have a
very very serious
opening advantage so let's jump into it
here
let's start with the move e4 and the
move c6
jumping into the kerocon all right d4 d5
and the line i want to
take a look at here is the line with the
exchange
e takes d5 and c takes d5
so who is familiar with the exchange
caro khan
and who's ahead of me here already
picking out
which type of piece we are going to be
targeting
with the white pieces uh go ahead and
post it in the chat if you want i'm not
going to pause just yet though
natural development for white would be
bishop d3 of course
black can play the move knight c6 we see
c3 and now knight f6 and i want to pause
here now
white to move and find an interesting
idea
to target one of black's pieces and i
mean target in this case
not as in threaten to capture but at
target
as in prevent development one of black's
pieces
their development can be prevented here
very very seriously
and if black's not careful black could
get into
a very seriously bad position
so white to move here with an
interesting opening idea of course there
are many moves
for white in this position but yeah
professor axis in the chat once again
has the idea the move h3 is very very
common here and i think
bobby fischer was sort of famous for
playing in this way at least he's a
bishop d3 and c3 i don't know if he
really came up with this h3 idea
but the idea here is that we've taken
away the f5 square from the bishop
and now white takes away the g4 square
as well
and now i want to ask you guys what
should black do
in response to this h3 idea if black
is not careful this bishop is not going
to get development developed and he's
going to be worse
and and we'll take a look at that for
sure but what should black do
to ensure that he's not worse out of the
opening here there are really two big
ideas
that you can choose from
two big ideas
so yeah the chat room is along the right
idea they're mentioning the move g6
but who can tell me why g6 is solving
these opening problems
for black the chat has also come around
to the second big idea
which is this move e5 and e5 is a very
you know principled move you your
opponent is wasting time with h3 so
black should
counter attack in the center and of
course this is solving the problem of
the bishop
by just opening up the position if we
take a look we can see d
e5 95 knight f3 for example
and it takes d3 with check and
eventually we'll see
that with the light squared bishop off
the board black doesn't have
any real issues in developing this guy
either for example bishop e3
and black can now
develop this guy at his leisure along
this open diagonal
coming to e6 in some cases or also
coming out
in the other way but the idea i want to
focus on here
is this move g6 g6 is a great way to
solve black's opening problems
in in this case
all right so what is the idea
of g6 here why does g6
fight against this opening idea
so all right i'm not sure if the
chatroom has is coming around to the
idea just yet
but g6 solves black's opening issues
because black is actually
planning to come to f5 anyways this is
the very direct idea
the point is after white continues
development we are ready to play bishop
f5
and we are willing to give up this pawn
structure
in order to number one secure the e4
square
and number two make sure our bishop gets
developed make sure it gets off the c8
square
and gets into the game and yeah this
opening line
is perfectly fine now for black when all
of his pieces are going to be
contributing
to the game i also want to ask you guys
another question in this position though
after something like e6
and let's just play a few more moves
here for example
uh bishop f4 bishop g7
knight bd2 well actually
probably bishop d6 is fine here but
let's just say the game continues like
this
knight bd2 something like castles
95 and something like knight e4 for
example
so why is this bishop for black
not a problem here it looks like this
bishop isn't actually doing much
sort of just biting on a rock here on d4
but why can we count this bishop as
developed count this bishop as
in the game as contributing why is this
bishop
not bad is bishop f5 actually playable
yeah bishop f5 is one of the main
variations in this opening
number one it's controlling the it's
defending the king
and controlling the center a little bit
as well those are great points
in number two we actually have a plan to
improve it we have a plan here as black
to break down these dark squares from
white
with a minority attack of b5 and b4
so it's really really important that we
understand that this bishop
is not a bad piece because it is number
one
compensating for the fact that we gave
up a g pawn and number two
it is going to be improved later on due
to
black's very very natural plan okay
and so yeah you guys did great here once
again the point of h3
is to prevent this bishop from
developing and so black of course should
play something like g6
or e5 fighting back against this idea
very very
directly now i want to take a look at
what happens if black
sort of concedes and just plays this
move e6 right if you're unfamiliar with
the opening
you might think ah whatever all right my
opponent stopped me from developing my
bishop
i'll just play the move e6 and it should
be fine
well in this case you
are very much going to be worse out of
the opening
thanks to this bishop on c8 not getting
developed
is h3 a good idea h3 is a playable idea
of course
in chess openings there should always be
ways to equalize in most of the main
variations
so just because black can equalize
doesn't mean h3 is a bad idea
it just means you know it's it's going
to be a chess game
so e6 and now white's job in the opening
is is sort of completed he's prevented
you from developing this bishop to a
good square
and now white just develops normally
something like net f3 bishop d6
castles castles rookie one and we'll see
with very very simple normal development
uh
knight e5 bishop b7 knight d2
knight f4 for example g6 g4
and now h4 in this case and white
has a very very pleasant advantage by
the way this is taken from a game
between anish geary and someone with the
last name
of riazantsev who's around 2650
2650 level grand master and the point
i'm getting at here
is this piece is not contributing to
this chess game
and that is why uh anish geary is able
to sort of go for this
crazy king said attack because this
bishop is not playing and this bishop is
going to be a useful attacker for white
now in the game black actually did
manage to fight back and draw against
geary
which you know make your jokes in the
comments now but
the point is geary got a very pleasant
opening advantage
thanks to this bishop not contributing
to the game
and again because of that he was able to
go for these this kingside attack
and probably should have won the game
with good play
all right backing on up let's take a
look at a couple more examples here
for example in d4 once again let's go
back
d5 c4 c6 i want to take another look at
the slav
and here the move c takes d5 c takes d5
comes into the exchange slot and this is
a line that i actually play myself
bishop f4 knight c6 e3
e6 and in this case e6
is fine for black and we'll talk about
why in just a moment
bishop d3 knight f6 for example
knight c3 bishop d6 and
this is the move that i'm actually going
to take issue with here bishop d6
so here i would
like you guys to play with the white
pieces
white to move and get a very
solid opening advantage a very solid
opening advantage
and this one is a little bit deeper than
my last question so take a few seconds
see if you can find some way to secure a
permanent opening advantage here
white to move what can you guys come up
with change off black's good bishop i
mean that's a start
that's a start but it's not the end of
it
it's not the end of it
so let's talk about what the point of
black's opening play was
right black played e6 very quickly sort
of trapping in this bishop
but then he followed it up with bishop
d6 and with bishop d6
what is he doing well he's fighting for
very serious control over this e5 square
right and what happens if black gains
control
over the e5 square well then he's
probably going to push a pawn to it
and after pawn to e5 of course then this
bishop can once again
come back to life and breathe so the
stable opening advantage that i'm
talking about
directly fights against black's idea of
pushing for e5
and activating his pieces
so see if you guys can come up with it
with this hint so yeah
manny has a beautiful idea you can take
on d6
queen takes d6 and now rather than the
natural move knight f3
when black has the option to play e5 in
most cases
we can play the stellar move f4 taking
advantage of the fact
that we know that this bishop cannot
really get developed comfortably
after the move f4 just for your
reference
from an opening database that i'm using
this position has been reached well over
100 times and after the move f4
white wins 46 of the time with a 34
draw rate and after the move knight f3
and castles black wins 92
sorry black doesn't win 92 percent of
the time black draws
well both players draw 92 percent of the
time so that is
a well over 30 percent uh difference
in the games from this one decision
so f4 i think very clearly gives
practical
opening advantages as well as well as i
think objective opening advantages
thanks to hampering the development of
this bishop
where knight f3 would allow eventually
of course
black to break in the center with e5 and
develop this bishop
along this open light diagonal
30 where var wins no i don't think var
plays this line in this this way
var goes for uh goes for an earlier
knight f3 and it has his own way of
fighting back
against this variation
um but yeah the point i'm getting at is
always be on the lookout for these
opportunities
to hamper your opponent's development
early early on
all right and i do have one more example
i want you guys to take a look at
so once again we're going to start with
d4 d5
c4 c6 and in this case let's start with
net f3
knight f6 knight c3 g6
c takes d5 c takes d5 and
bishop f4 bishop g7 and now e3
and this one is not going to be a white
to move or a black to move puzzle
i want to ask you guys what is the
evaluation of this
opening position does white have an
advantage is it equal
does black somehow have an advantage
tell me what you think
tell me what you think and why
tell me what you think here
plus 0.2 says someone in the chat so
more or less equal
quantum head says white is more
developments turkey says white has the
advantage but he doesn't say why
professor axis gives me the name of the
variation and says it's plus equals
and so yeah manny has finally hit upon
the correct reasoning here
once again it all comes down to fighting
against
one of black's pieces in this case black
chose to bring this bishop out to g7
very early on and white has managed to
play against that
by removing this c pawn right we see
that after g6
white chose to take on d5 and black
recaptured with the c
pawn and this was a very deliberate
decision
by white to make this bishop bad how
does it make this bishop bad
well this bishop on g7 only makes sense
if
it has a future on this open diagonal
remember we talked about this briefly
in the cairo khan variation that i
mentioned where
that bishop does have a future because
black can go for a minority attack on
the queen's side
in this variation that future is very
very dim because c5 is not playable
and black has no way of undermining this
pawn on d4
and so white has an advantage here
simply because
this bishop is not going to be developed
well
white has targeted this bishop in the
opening and has an advantage because
because of it and once again you need
only to look at the the database scores
to to see this reflected white wins
about 50
of the time here which is sort of an
absurd winning rate
uh and that's just about going to do it
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
lecture where we took a look
at some opening ideas from the recent
chess 9lx event
where some of the top players found
themselves in trouble quite early on
and then we took a look at how this is
reflected in a variety of different
chess
openings once again those two key ideas
i really went over tonight
the idea of targeting weak squares early
on in the opening which does show up in
chess
and the idea of targeting one of your
opponent's pieces to make it bad to make
it stay
out of the game these two very specific
ideas
are sort of everywhere in normal chess
openings
we just don't always think about them
because we're so used to
sort of just studying the theory rather
than understanding
these really key principles behind them
if you guys are watching live we are
going to be continuing next
with a tactics time class live on twitch
if you're watching the youtube version
that is going to be all from us here
tonight
thank you so much for joining me once
again my name is caleb denby and i will
see you next time
you